so vivo no non ci posso credere senso
riuscito ho vinto ho vinto voi adesso mi
dovete spiegare avevano in testa i
creatori di so cosa gli è passato per il
cervello va bene così non importa è
stato meraviglioso ha battuto la sua
faccia alla fine siamo così giunti al
finale di harry stickman lo so che è
difficile per voi arrivare alla fine di
una serie che non ha avuto senso ma che
merita in qualche modo anche per me lo è
stato perché poi non ne sono più usciti
però oggi la finiamo con ceiling diamond
dopo essere fuggito in una prigione dopo
essersi fidato in un complesso dopo
essersi implicato in un èquipe dopo
essersi dopo essere scappato dalla
prigione dopo essersi infiltrato in un
complesso in un hershey qualsiasi cosa
abbiamo e finale dove harry stickman
prova a rubare il diamante ceiling diane
ladd che io non so benissimo perché non
mi ricordo non mi ricordo niente ma
questo in teoria dovrebbe essere uno dei
pi incasinate adesso vediamo
l'obiettivo rubare il diamante io sono
sempre ristic man
[Musica]
archeologica del debito era la
televisione
wow io l'ho visto ci faccio i soldi non
è il globo prendo la macchina
let's go che quest altro lo tengono in
un museo ovviamente da come è fatto
sembra più che essere l'ultimo sembra
essere il primo non solo sicuro jalali
fatto uscire nell'ordine giusto si sisti
stickman però la boe bustin hosni kickin
slick in cioè provavano tattica un po
più easy della serie non facciamoci
vedere
ok jump quindi passiamo dall'alto dal
basso io direi dall'alto già un po jumbo
o per chissà che non si sa che non è
proprio quello che pensavo ok ritrae
facevo antigravity gap cioè io me lo
metti in testa e nono gravità va bene
perché mettervelo intorno alla mano ecco
non funziona per riordinare da lì
express non è sempre il massimo
gli urla chi hai all we want to go space
che magari non così prova teleport era
il vico cosa che mi manca per entrare
dall'alto da effettivamente funzionato
incredibile salvaguardia che ovviamente
non mi ha visto poco punch solo un uomo
è in grado di utilizzare il falcon punch
ovviamente pila l'invisibilità beh è
stato molto semplice a è difficile
vedere mentre se invisibile verrà sono
caduto ok ragazzi sarà più difficile del
previsto prendere sto diamante non sono
ancora intrappolati tranquilla heiser
cene lo sapevo che tanto non l'avrei
preso sapevo perfetta dalle ventole
premi è l'unico rimasto
alla fine del premier a la cosa giusta
cioè ti pare che questo sinistra e per
un penny quando c'è un diamante l'iva
però portal gun subito porca vacca di
pirla
niente lo più infinito e vabbè ai
sorprese di hoover e taiwan tutti e da
un derby da mesi importo al tecnologico
ed street dove va
vabbè e non penso di si sia mai letta
sta pappardella quindi andiamo avanti
drop prova a cadere sul ministro non è
proprio stata la mia migliore idea da
quando ho iniziato questo video wire
sempre l'ultima quella che faccia quella
che azzecco la laser cattero m tutti
userebbero il laser cutter che mi sembra
molto easy aiuto il martello
hai visto per una volta ci ho azzeccato
per una volta che hanno ucciso clank
qualcosa ci devi fare quando il
formaggio screen per curiosità ah ok che
non lo vedo molto molto impacciato
rispetto al solito e restituendo
molto più impacciato almeno hai salvato
beppe bè certo plank fratelli stata più
vestiti potevi semplicemente camminare a
questo punto va beh siamo quasi fuori
ragazzi posso usare il diamante stesso e
proviamo
beh io sarei felice di ricevere un
diamante così di testa
[Musica]
molto bene è stato molto più semplice
del previsto in realtà è molto più
semplice andiamo avanti ragazzi sarà un
deficit da super smash bros
vabbè ragazzi vi proviamo a centrale pro
stavolta col basse in ammazza questo
tipo tokyo nella casa di kurt amico
prima ancora che la casa di carta
uscisse ma no non è una moto che
scherzavo io non ho fatto a ok
a dover schiacciare i tasti al momento
giusto sa bene re tra i non è andata
bene anche così però chi come questa
parte è molto più difficile ragazzi rem
che non ho ben capito
ecco esattamente come in tokyo nella
casa di casa mi piace questo gioco sono
tutti svegli emma roberts potete darmi
un secondo per decina almeno leggere
cose la mazza mena mena yemer ai è
bravissimo lancia affonda mia che schifo
[Musica]
scudo è normale sono bravissimo talk e
basket ha fatto troppo tardi e vasquez
da dove l'ha tirato non è non c'era ha
infatti meno male perché nominate fu
cable all'attacco dietro va bene neanche
la pista non posso usare come arma
proprio sul quadro la rabbia di zeus
merito attentatore alla fine match
nesting stingray
c'è la polizia wow nelle reazioni
proprio sono me la cavo roccia tira
gliela bravissimo ma che trova una
roccia di grosso e va bene un attimo fa
mi leggere un attimo quarto tempo mamma
mia roccia quello a sinistra a
prescindere non lo leggo neanche ma con
la sinistra con la buona bubble
beh righe
[Musica]
ok
ok qua non solo devo saltare l'affare
aglio sorriso semplicemente ha tentato
di convincerlo drive diamond sono stato
bravissimo
sono io il diamante diamante zio
diamante ecco
[Musica]
amici guarda quanto affezionato ce l'ho
fatta e forse il più corto di tutti
ceiling diamond può essere però è
veramente figo c'è tra tutti quanti
veramente figo non so se ne esistono
altri perché veramente non ho mai visti
altri di siccome però ditemi se non
merita la vita
ragazzi miei siccome ho finito la serie
di harry stickman per la seconda volta
tra ho detto seconda volta ho fatto così
dicevo se conoscete un qualche cosa di
simile è carino che posso fare al posto
di ieri stigma visto che a me piace
tantissimo peccato che abbiano fatto
solo cinque episodi
se conoscete qualcosa fatemelo sapere
che sicuramente lo porto perché
veramente figo quindi amici miei spero
che vi sia piaciuto come al solito
subito piaciuta al momento è come vi
piace al video anche vari social che
come noi vita una posizione se non si
dovesse iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo
come sempre al seguito da ragazzi
[Musica]